Perry matthw Matthew Perry le mythique
chandleur de F moi je regardais jamais
funs mais j'ai vu que tout le monde
c'était c'était incroyable bien sûr
c'est vrai que voilà moi je regardais tu
regardais très peu moi j'étais sur les
Chevaliers du
Zodiaque chandleur nous a quitté bien
sûr je connaissait sur matthw Perry on
va revenir sur ça regardez myiam Palomba
donc spécialiste des raceras sera avec
nous dans un instant elle va nous
raconter tout nous raconter comment ça
s'est passé parce que c'est une mort
étrange quand même Gilles Verdez qui est
aussi spécialiste en ras la
vidéo c'était le blagueur maladroit de
la bande quand je sors je conclus jamais
Chandler Bing mat Perry l'a incarné
pendant 10 ans dans la
série les fans ont comme le sentiment
d'avoir perdu un ami ce regard ce côté
un peu ce côté un peu maladroit aussi et
ce oui c'est le personnage bien sûr
depuis des années il luttait contre son
addiction aux analgésiques et à l'alcool
pour les fans Matth Perry continuera à à
travers chler Bing le personnage
sûrement le plus attachant de la
bande bonsoir myiam merci d'être là 1er
novembre en plus pas
payé qu'est-ce qui non merci qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ma mimi et bien donc
Matth Perry a été retrouvé mort dans son
jacuzzi samedi dernier un appel
téléphonique a été lancé au pomp à vers
16h ils sont arrivés sur place pour
constater que le corps était inanimé ils
l'ont retrouvé la tête sortie de l'eau
dans son jacuzzi complètement bah mort
et et du coup cette cette mort est
extrêmement mystérieuse parce qu'on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui de quoi vraiment
est-il mort il y a tout un tas
d'analyses qui ont été faites et et
voilà Gilles les premières analyses
toxicologiques n'ont pas révélé de
présence de drogue notamment le fameux
fantanil là cette drogue qui qui qui bal
les États-Unis mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas autre chose et ils ont
retrouvé des médicaments avec une
ordonnance donc pour l'instant il y a
pas prise de drogue mais il diffèent à
plusieurs mois les vraies raisons du
décès donc il y a un mystère la la la la
le fantany et la métamphétamine n'ont
pas été effectivement retrouvé dans dans
dans les analyses toxicologiques pareil
aucune drogue n'a été retrouvé chez lui
hein des des drogues comme la cocaïne et
cetera il ne et par contre il ne peuvent
même pas dire s'il est il s'est noyé ou
pas donc il a un véritable véritable
mystère pour l'instant il il metett de
côté la piste criminel he l'assassinat
de de de de Matthew Perry mais le
mystère est est extrêmement important
tout autour de cette mort il y a une
piste qui exploré c'est celle de l'arrêt
cardiaque puce qu'il a fait 2 heures de
sport avant de de mourir il a fait du
pickle ball c'est un mélange entre le
paddle le tennis et le pingpong il a
joué 2 heur il aurait été très fatigué
et 2 heures après cette partie plus de
nouvelles donc il pense éventuellement à
arrêt cardiaque ah ouais ah ouais
d'accord alors faut quand même aussi
savoir qu'il était c'était quelqu'un qui
était qui était malade hein il avait il
avait passé plusieurs mois à l'hôpital
il avait une perforation
gastrointestinale à cause des e piacés
qu'il consommait à haute dose donc voilà
il avait déjà été pendant 2 semaines
dans le coma c'était quelqu'un aussi qui
était qui était alcoolique qui prenait
énormément de de de médicaments donc
tout tout tout peut-être possible en
fait sur les condition Mor qui est
incroyable he parce que c'est que Daniel
il était non mais depuis l'âge de 14 ans
et quand il a été embauché pour la série
il savait lui qu'il était alcoolique
personne ne le savait mais c'est vrai
que du coup c'est lui qui a vieilli le
plus vite dans la série en fait il a eu
un accident il a eutant que ça qui me il
a eu un accident de ski dans les dans
Fin fin des années 90 et en fait il a
été il a été accro vicondine et et du
coup à cette anentalgique qui
malheureusement fait beaucoup de dégâts
aux États-Unis 55 comprimés par jour à
un moment 55 comprimés par jour de ces
opioïde qui crée en fait une vraie
addiction donc il a été il a eu une
addiction terrible aux opioïdes il il a
dépensé 9 millions de dollars pour 15
cur 65 9 millions de
dollars5 de désation désespéré il
tentait à chaque fois ses collègues
l'ont aidé tant qu'il pouvait il
arrivait parfois hors d'état il disait
même à la fin je n'ai même pas vu que je
tournais le dernier épisode de Friends
il avait des absence il a été soutenu
mais effectivement on se demande s'il y
a une une prise de quelque chose une
résurg est-ce qu'il était libéré de ses
addictions voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a
une carrière brillante ici mais une vie
extrêmement tourmentée il a dit des
choses très belles dans son
autobiographie ù il dit effectivement
que il a essayé plein de fois et que
quand quand il all il a écrit quand je
vais mourir on parlera de Friends
j'aimerais aussi qu'on dise tout ce que
j'ai fait pour les gens qui étaient
addictes parce que j'ai pas réussi à me
sauver moi j'ai fait énormément de cur
et cetera mais j'ai monté des des des
des clinqu il cré j'ai créé des centres
et cetera et je voudrais qu'on se
souvienne de ça et qu'on se souvienne à
quel point j'ai essayé d'aider les
autres même si j'y arrive pas forcément
pour moi donc ça c'est aussi joli je
trouve et qu'on qu'on parle aussi de ça
fa al Matthieu Perry est mort ce samedi
donc dans sa résidence de Los Angeles
aux États-Unis il avait 53 ans il a été
retrouvé dans son jacuzzi hasard
incroyable il y a 7 jours la dernière
photo que l'acteur avait publié sur
insta l'affiche dans ce même jacuzzi où
il a été retrouvé s vie c'est fou ça oui
oui c'est des pas beaucoup de fans se
sont exprimés sur sur cette photo et ont
vu ça comme quelque chose de
prémonitoire c'est c'est assez étrange
effectivement alors le médecin le bureau
du médecin légiste dans le cas où la
cause du décès ne peut-être déterminé au
moment de l'autopsie un certificat
différé sera délivré jusqu'à ce que des
études supplémentaires aient été réalisé
pas de réponse alors effectivement la
piste criminelle n'est pas abordée mais
c'est quand même la division des
homicides du fameux LAPD c'est les
policiers de Los Angeles c'est la
division des homicides qui gère ça et
tant qu'on aura pas les résultats en
profondeur des analyses toxicologiques
il y a une autopsie bien évidemment ça
peut prendre 4 à 6 mois il ne donneront
pas les réelles causes du décès alors
matthie Perry de de F bien sûr a
également révélé avoir frollé la mort à
de nombreuses reprises leors
d'hospitalisation raison comme vous
l'avez dit sa consommation abusive de
drogue et d'alcool les médecins ont dit
à ma famille que j'avais 2 % de chance
de vivre on m'a mis sous une machine
appelée ECMO qui assure la respiration
du cœur et des poumons c'est ce qu'on
appelle un av Maria personne ne survit à
cela donc ça peut être des séquelles
voilà aussi comme c'est c'est en 2020
son cœur s'était arrêté hein oui oui
s'était arrêté et puis je vous dire en
2018 il est resté quand même de semaines
dans le coma donc c'est c'est c'est pas
rien son colon avait éclaté donc il
avait voilà il avait une santé fragile
et c'est vrai que même moi qui regardais
pas F c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu ça ça
m'a je me suis dit c'est c'est dingue ça
a marqué une génération c'est vraiment
un pour le coup c'est une série qui a
marqué une une génération et et il y a
des il y a des séries comme ça qui font
partie de la pop culture et cette série
fait partie de la pop culture chacun
s'identifia l'un ou l'autre des
personnages et c'est il a accompagné
beaucoupourhui regard et les jeunes
regardent effectivement friends c'est
vraiment 1 million de dollars par
épisode he les derniers épisodes 1
million de dollars parce que c'était un
succès planétaire et le dernier épisode
ça a été retransmis à manatan il y avait
une foule immense pour regarder le
dernier épisode il y a des expositions
qui ont été reconstituées où les gens se
bouscul pour les derniers épisodes
d'ailleurs c'est une c'est une des
séries où les acteurs sont tous payés la
même chose c'està-dire que à un moment
ils se sont rendus compte que peut-être
il y en avait qui étaent plus payé que
d'autres ils se sont ligués parce que
c'était réellement des amis ils se sont
tous mis ensemble ils sont allés voir la
production en disant on arrête de
tourner si on n pas tous payer au même
prix ils étaient inconnu au début
d'ailleurs il y a une info qui vient de
sortir c'est que la l'actrice Lisa cudro
fibi fibi exactement la série voilà j'ai
vu de trois fois dans la série cult fun
aussi envisagerait de récupérer Alfred
le chien son ami décédé pour vous dire
ils étaient tous vraiment très amis ah
ou oui ils étaient très amis alors il y
a pas eu d'histoire d'amour entre eux
hein quand même faut le savoir mais en
tout cas oui oui c'était très très
proche et et d'ailleurs on le voit sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a beaucoup de
de photos de ensemble encore aujourd'hui
et ils ont jamais coupé lien comme ça
peut arriver souvent en tracteur oui
monre chroniicur euh fa savoir qu'il
comprend le lien il était adoré parce
que dans la série c'est de l'humour en
permanence des punchlin àouva et après
les gens ont découvert que cet humour
cachait des failles une détresse donc il
a été encore plus apprécié aux
États-Unis où il faisait l'unanimité
malgré ses addictions si je puis dire
oui les acteurs de fr ils sont pas
encore trop exprimés parce qu'ils vont
faire un hommage commun ensemble pour
lui lui lui rendre hommage suite à sa
mort il y a pas eu de réaction c'est
vrai que ça sur surpren les si si ils
ont dit ils ont dit qu'ils étaient tous
effondrés ils ont enfin communiqué voilà
et et même les les producteurs se sont
exprimés en disant que la dernière fois
qu'il l'avait vu cà dire assez récemment
il était plutôt heureux jovial
apparemment il s'en était sorti de ses
addictions donc si si ils ont ils ont
quand même parlé mais effectivement ils
vont il y a un événement un peu plus
grand qui devrait arriver pour célébrer
sa mémoire mais mais les dernières
années sont pas très très gayes pour lui
dans ses Mémoires qui sont sortis
l'année dernière donc il avait 53 ans il
espérait encore retrouver l'amour avoir
des enfants c'était une une faille et et
son dernier rôle en fait qui qui sera
donc son dernier rôle c'était avec
Leonardo
decaprio de Caprio pardon Leonardo
DiCaprio il y a 2 ans ça a été coupé au
montage donc c'est il il a enchaîné de
Caprio la
pizzeria il a il il a enchaîné les bids
que ça soit au cinéma à la télévision
même au théâtre he ça a été il y a eu
des des gros bids et il a jamais réussi
à rebondir à play friends côté amour il
a été brièvement fiancé là quand on
quand on regarde par exemple un S qui
est très connu aux États-Unis TMZ ils
ont retrouvé sa dernière petite amie
enfin en tout cas relation peut-être
d'un soir seulement un jeune mannequin
de 25 ans mais rien de bien sérieux il y
a quelqu'un qui me dit que dans la série
F il y a Rachel qui a une histoire avec
Ross quand même oui avec rossou c'est
assez bref la vraie vie s'était pris une
veste avec Jennifer Aniston 3 ans avant
qui joue ens il a été avec Julia Roberts
d'ailles la raison pour laquelle Julia
Roberts fait un caméo elle apparaît dans
dans une dans un épisode effectivement
voilà et et il dit j'ai quitté Jul je m'
mordai les doigts toute ma vie enfin
voilà parce qu'il a été absolument
amoureux d'elle et il aa quitté parce
qu'il dit je l'ai quitté avant qu'elle
me me quitte parce que j'aurais été
dévastée qu'elle me quitte en fait il
éta mais quand vous rendez compte si
Guillaume quand on nous quitte un jour
nous dira il avait été avec Julien et
Robert c'est incroyable écoute voilà en
tout cas voilà bah matthie Perry bah
voilà c'était c'était non mais c'est
vrai que ça a été un un déferlement très
triste honnêtement grand émotion
mondiale exactement
surtout partout on parle que de ça par
merci Miriam d'avoir été avec nous euh
vous viendrez nous voir pour d'autres
raseras au cours de la semaine